en una parte de la futura África
es aceptada en la mejor universidad de la galaxia,
a planetas de distancia?
¿Qué pasa si ella decide ir?
Este es un extracto de la trilogía de mi novela "Binti":
Encendí el transportador y dije una oración silenciosa.
No tenía idea de qué iba a hacer si no funcionaba.
Mi transportador era barato,
incluso una gota de humedad o, más probablemente, un grano de arena,
podría ocasionar un cortocircuito.
Era defectuoso y la mayoría de las veces tenía que reiniciarlo una y otra vez
antes de que funcionara.
"Por favor, no ahora, por favor, no ahora", pensé.
El transportador se estremeció en la arena y contuve la respiración.
Diminuto, plano y negro como una piedra de oración,
zumbó suavemente y luego se izó lentamente de la arena.
Finalmente, produjo la fuerza elevadora de equipaje.
Sonreí.
Ahora podría llegar a la lanzadera a tiempo.
Me quité otjize de la frente con mi dedo índice y me arrodillé
luego toqué el dedo con la arena,
encallándolo en la arcilla roja de olor dulce.
"Gracias", susurré.
Era un paseo de media milla por el oscuro camino del desierto.
Con el transportador funcionando, llegaría a tiempo.
Enderezando, me detuve y cerré los ojos.
Ahora, el peso de toda mi vida estaba presionando mis hombros.
Estaba desafiando la parte más tradicional de mí por primera vez
en toda mi vida.
Me estaba yendo en la oscuridad de la noche, y ellos no tenían ni idea.
Mis nueve hermanos, todos mayores que yo, excepto mi hermana menor y mi hermano,
nunca habían visto venir esto.
Mis padres nunca imaginarían que haría tal cosa en un millón de años.
Para cuando todos se dieran cuenta de lo que había hecho y hacia dónde iba,
me habría ido ya del planeta.
En mi ausencia, mis padres se gruñirían el uno al otro
que yo nunca más volvería a poner un pie en su casa.
Mis cuatro tías y dos tíos que vivían en el camino
gritarían y chismorrearían entre sí
sobre cómo había escandalizado a toda la línea de sangre.
Iba a ser un paria.
"Vamos", susurré suavemente al transportador,
pateando mi pie.
Los delgados anillos de metal alrededor de cada tobillo tintineaban ruidosamente,
pero volví a patear mi pie.
Una vez encendido, el transportador funcionó mejor cuando no lo toqué.
"Vamos", dije de nuevo, el sudor se concentraba en mi frente.
Al no moverse nada, pensé
dar un empujón a dos maletas grandes que estaban sobre el campo de fuerza.
Se movieron suavemente y suspiré aliviada.
Al menos algo de suerte estaba de mi lado.
Y en una futura lejana parte de África,
Binti es una genio matemática del grupo étnico Himba.
Ella había sido aceptada en una universidad en otro planeta,
y ella decidió ir.
Llevando la sangre de su gente en sus venas,
adornada con las enseñanzas, formas, incluso con la tierra en su propia piel,
Binti deja la Tierra.
A medida que avanza la historia, ella no se vuelve otra, sino más.
Esta idea de irse pero trayendo y luego volverse más
está en uno de los corazones del afrofuturismo,
o simplemente puede llamarse un tipo diferente de ciencia ficción.
Puedo explicar mejor
la diferencia entre la ciencia ficción clásica y el afrofuturismo
si utilizo la analogía del pulpo.
Como los humanos,
los pulpos son unas de las criaturas más inteligentes del planeta.
Pero la inteligencia del pulpo evolucionó a partir de una línea evolutiva diferente,
a la de los seres humanos,
así que la base es diferente.
Lo mismo se puede decir sobre las bases de las diversas formas de ciencia ficción.
Gran parte de la ciencia ficción especula
sobre tecnologías, sociedades, asuntos sociales,
que hay más allá de nuestro planeta, y que hay dentro de nuestro planeta.
La ciencia ficción es una de las mejores y más efectivas formas
de escritura política.
Se trata de la pregunta: "¿Y si?"
Aún así, no toda la ciencia ficción tiene el mismo linaje ancestral,
esa línea es ciencia ficción occidental,
que es principalmente blanca y masculina.
Hablamos de Isaac Asimov, Julio Verne,
HG Wells, George Orwell, Robert Heinlein, etc.
Y, ¿qué pasa si una nigeriana- estadounidense escribiera ciencia ficción?
Al crecer, no leí mucha ciencia ficción.
No podía relacionarme con estas historias
preocupada por la xenofobia, la colonización
y viendo extraterrestres como otros.
Y no veía ningún reflejo de alguien que se pareciera a mí en esas narraciones.
En la trilogía de novela "Binti",
Binti deja el planeta para buscar educación de los extraterrestres.
Ella se va como es,
mirando la forma como ella se ve,
llevando su cultura,
siendo quien es ella
Me inspiré a escribir esta historia
no porque siguiera una línea de narrativas de obras clásicas espaciales,
sino debido a la sangre que corre profundamente
por la familia, el conflicto cultural
y la necesidad de ver a una niña africana abandonar el planeta por su cuenta.